it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr alok kenosha who's a
psychiatrist
practicing in boston massachusetts and
on the faculty at harvard medical school
also the co-founder of healthy gamer an
organization
using meditation and advances in
neuroscience and coaching
to help gamers take back control of
their lives
it's great to have you back on today
thanks a lot david it's a pleasure to be
here again
so what are you seeing generally maybe
to get us into the conversation
about what's going on with people's
mental health and psyche and sort of
predisposition to what is now
starting to hopefully be an exit from
from the pandemic
yeah so it's a great question so during
the pandemic we saw um
an increase in depressive symptoms uh so
there was a paper by the journal of the
american medical association which
basically found a 300 percent
worsening in depression during the
pandemic
and so as people were sort of getting
enclosed um also like
lower access to vitamin d and things
like that resulted in worsening
depression
the really fascinating thing is i'm
seeing something that i really haven't
heard
clinically described which i would call
reintegration anxiety
which is very unusual um but basically
people have been enclosed
so long and i see this a lot in the
university students that we work with
that they're like actually concerned
about like they want to re-engage
with the real world but they feel
anxious that socially they become rusty
they're not sure that they're going to
be able to do in-person school
so it's really interesting because
there's almost some degree of like fear
about reintegrating
into the real world some of this i
see in in a very um what seems more
like just unknowns about the data
right which is okay when i go to the
grocery store
and i see people without a mask now i'm
imagining
that there is just virus coming out of
their mouth right it's because this is
this is what
we the idea that was sort of ingrained
in us before vaccination and and so on
and so forth
but you're saying this goes beyond just
waiting to understand and feel good
about the science it's something above
and beyond this
yeah absolutely so if we look at like
our brains
when we don't use a particular circuit
in our brain
it rusts so if i speak two languages and
i don't speak one of the languages for a
year i get rusty
yup so what we find in covid is everyone
is interacting online
so there are parts of our brain which
make us feel socially reassured
like the parts of our brain which will
interpret body language
tone facial expressions and things like
that which on online interactions we
don't really get
so now as people are starting to
reintegrate into society and like
socially be active in person those rusty
circuits of our brain are causing us to
like
not feel reassured and i'm seeing this
bizarre spike in social anxiety
as people are reintegrating yeah and
it's really strange
there are people um there are people i
know which is related i think to social
anxiety who have said you know i went to
the grocery store
and they're back to full capacity i was
wearing a mask but some people weren't
and i just
almost had like a panic response like i
i'm just gonna
take my two items i've grabbed and not
finish my shop and i'm leaving
is that a sort of uh agoraphobia type
response that's taking place
i i wouldn't quite call it agoraphobia
because if we think about agoraphobia
it's the it's usually like the inability
to control
circumstances which causes you to
retreat into your home
um what i really think it is is almost
what you were saying we've been sort of
conditioned
to fear people without masks
right we've been told there have been
death tolls and stories about
you know refrigeration trucks filled
with bodies with covid
there's a lot of information about these
new variants which are ripping through
countries that previously were doing
pretty well so i think the people
especially who have
taken that to heart and have been
careful are going to be the ones that
will
you know we've we've conditioned
ourselves to be afraid of that thing
so it's almost like a conditioned
response like a conditioned fear
that now we have to start undoing i've
told my audience that all along i've
followed cdc guidelines even when i
didn't really think i needed to be
wearing a mask on the bike path outdoors
i did it because people around me were
and it was sort of like a social
calculation that that i made
and now as masks are coming off i've
said
you know i was just traveling and where
i went
people weren't wearing masks in grocery
stores so i didn't either but then
when i got back i stick my head into the
grocery store i mostly see masks i put
my mask on
i have no medical reason why i'm doing
that right the cdc guidelines are i
don't need that mask
is it in some way bad that i'm doing
this
merely to just not stand out as the guy
not wearing a mask is there some
some concerning longer term impact of me
behaving in that way
well let's start by understanding why
you behave that way which is because
your brain is wired to behave
that way okay right so if we think about
you know how do children
learn language how do children learn
body like you know
body movements and if we think about as
our language evolves over time you know
we start to use new slang
it's because our brain is literally
wired we're communal
animals as homo sapiens and we look at
what the
other homo sapiens are doing and we are
going to feel like doing the same thing
it's why peer pressure is a thing it's
why fashion fads are a thing it's just
the way that
we're wired now what impact that's gonna
have on you i mean i don't really know i
think it's just part of the way we all
are and and you're gonna kind of be like
monkey see monkey do yeah which to a
sense is fine
i think the real challenge comes when
there are for example cdc guidelines and
large populations of people
who don't want to follow them right so
this is where they're kind of like
monkey see monkey do brain is telling
them oh don't bother wearing a mask
when it really is important because
there are new strains there are other
kinds of considerations to really think
about
um and so i i don't really i'm not
concerned about the psychological impact
of like switching
whether you wear masks or not right
because everyone's going to
re-equilibrate
to like what's a you know what's a
healthy amount of mask wearing
speaking of equilibrium you mentioned
the significant increase
in in depression and reported depressive
symptoms during the pandemic i know many
people who have gone
on uh serotonin antidepressants the the
ones that have been around for for
decades at this point in time
what is the medical science at this
point about
the um from what i looked at before our
conversation it seems like a typical
course of those is often
like a 12 to 18 month period and then
often people start kind of coming off of
those
would it be expected that when people
get beyond
this phase of the pandemic where maybe
they don't feel that they need those
medications anymore
that they're going to go sort of back to
their pre-pandemic depressive state or
does this stuff tend to be sort of
sticky and persistent
uh so it's not going to be sticky and
persistent based on my professional
experience
okay i i i'm just going to say that i
don't think that
if you have a pandemic induced
depression i don't know that a ssri
is actually like an appropriate clinical
response
interesting so so let's remember that
depression is a symptom
actually and has multiple diagnoses that
can lead to depression
so you can have cancer-induced
depression you can have bipolar disorder
you can have major depressive disorder
you can have depressive symptoms
relating to trauma and what really ssris
have been studied
very well in is these neurochemical
imbalances really within major
depressive disorder
so i would first of all you know
personally i've been hesitant to just
prescribe ssris to people who are coming
in for the first time
depressed during the pandemic because we
know that depressive symptoms can be
highly circumstantial
and really changing those circumstances
is is really the permanent solution
that being said so if we kind of assume
that for a second i wouldn't expect that
the gigantic crop of people who got put
on ssris
will need them going forward um so i do
think it's reasonable to pull off of
medication within
i mean generally speaking i'll try
within six months to a year
um interesting i think 18 months is even
sounds a little bit long to me because
the data suggests that a depressive
episode resolves on its own within one
year
basically i want to talk a little bit
about
something that that's maybe a little
more in the political space and
whether you do or don't want to get
involved in the political commentary
part is fine but
we've been seeing uh what seems to me as
a kind of
coping mechanism for those who supported
the former president
in in the election um essentially
denying that he really lost and if we
think of
denial as maybe the first stage in a
process
sometimes in life um there seems to be
sort of like an inability to move on
from the denial phase that i'm noticing
and
he's going to be back in august or maybe
it's september and this type of thing
is that what what do you make of that do
people sometimes never move on from the
denial
phase um i i really
can't make much of that to be honest
because what i really like to do david
is like talk to these people right so
and see what's going on specifically
yeah so i mean i i definitely think that
people
can get attached to a particular idea
and they have trouble letting go of that
idea but i think if we really want to
understand
you know why the denial is so sticky to
use one of your words yeah i think the
real question is what does it
mean to these people that you know trump
did lose and what does it mean to these
people if he comes back
because usually what i find in in
persistent denial
yeah is that it's not the actual thing
it's what that thing
means to the person so the world will be
a better place and i want the world to
be a better place if
x y or z happens right and so i think
it's the association or the meaning
or the interpretation of the particular
event which makes the denial so sticky
so the maybe asking one of these folks
like when they call in to me
it what would it mean to you to accept
that
trump genuinely just did lose and that
might give me insight
into why they're not moving on from the
denial
yeah i would modify that question a
little bit i wouldn't say to accept what
did it mean what does it mean to you
if trump lost right you know what does
it mean to you
if he never comes back what would that
say about the world what would that say
because i i think what it is is it's
really the what it says about the world
is what they don't want to accept they
don't want to live in a world
where this kind of thing happens right
so they're going to continue
hoping that this is not the world that
they live in that would be my best guess
in your um in your practice do you
see people who who maybe have a
depressive
or an anxiety sort of uh a situation
that is caused by the sort of general
events that are taking place
in society not the pandemic is like a
very specific medical event but sort of
like
what they identify as a political
problem or something along those lines
absolutely dude so like this is why like
we started healthy gamer because i think
what's happening is depression
used to be an isolated neurochemical
imbalance a malfunction in the brain
right but there's almost like a societal
generational
or existential depression that we see
all throughout like gen z
in millennials to be honest and and so
like you know the world is just becoming
a bleak place
and how do people deal with that you
know when
when when how can i wake up as a
sophomore
in college when i know that every year
that goes by i'm racking up an
insurmountable amount of debt
that as i enter the job market i'm like
getting into a trench that i'm never
going to escape from
right how can i get the motivation to
study and if you go in to see a
psychiatrist they will
check certain boxes diagnose you with
depression and put you on a pill
and i just don't know that i mean can it
help absolutely could there be an
underlying
neurochemical malfunction absolutely but
i think part of the reason that healthy
gamer has grown so much
um and we basically just got started
right after i was on your show
the last time yeah is because they're
you know we need different kinds of
solutions
um in terms of dealing with these
different and new
like causes of depression like this
existential depression is absolutely
real
i mean the the student loan thing it's
almost like a capitalism-based
depression of sorts
yeah i mean so i think that this is
where like something something about the
way that our personal
psychology is being affected by world
events
seems to be a lot tighter so a hundred
years ago i don't know that world events
affected people's psychology so much
yeah but as world events
get pushed on our mind so much they
start to have a bigger personal effect
on us
and that's actually part of the reason
that we started as an organization
because i don't think the old systems of
psychiatry
are sufficient to deal with those kinds
of things
no question about that that part seems
that part seems abundantly clear
a healthy gamer is the organization
we've been speaking with its co-founder
dr
olok konoja who's a psychiatrist
practicing in boston massachusetts and
also on the faculty at harvard medical
school
always great speaking to you i
appreciate it thanks a lot david it was
a pleasure to be back